i wanted a crib close to the stadium
it's the bay rent's ridiculous so i got
some um
roommates
but this
this isn't what i signed up for i say
either
i say either
these guys
[Applause]
eddie said my life wouldn't be in danger
i woke up this morning with a tendril
wrapped around my neck
not cool there's a dang chew tire in the
living room what's that about
these guys just don't even like each
other that was abusive which is bad
because they share a body venom's got no
chill you are a loser
yeah some of us are trying to sleep so
sick i don't know how to tell eddie it's
not working without triggering them
i respect that aggression on a football
field but not in my living room that's
the third time this week dude not cool
venom let there be carnage exclusively
in movie theaters october 1st eddie
brock we've been waiting in the darkness
for you
on october 1st
the universe
is expanding it's something way bigger
than you and me
i'm done with this guy
why me
we all had secrets you know what secrets
wanted they went out
exclusively movie theaters october 1st
you